the balik people have lived in sepaku
East kalimantan for hundreds of years
but life is changing here as Indonesia
builds its new capital city nusantada
and this Village is now marked as part
of the development
they act like we don't exist like we're
not human they should have talked to us
first we accept the new capital but
don't dismiss our rights they want to
build something new by destroying what
is already here
lives in a house that once belonged to
her great-great-grandparents now she
wakes to the sound of heavy machinery in
her backyard as workers build an intake
reservoir for a dam to serve the new
capital
this is the impact of the development
behind me we never had to buy things
like wood or water or vegetables before
but now we live miserable lives advocacy
groups estimate around 20 000 indigenous
people will be affected officials say
those affected by the new capital
project will be compensated fairly but
many indigenous people in East
kalimantana don't have land certificates
making it difficult for them to have
their claims verified
indigenous people told us their land was
passed down from their ancestors until
recently they'd never had to prove
ownership
the project Chief insists their needs
are being considered I think we have to
respect them all the indigenous people
the local wisdom the way that they are
living working and also learning that
shall be part of our development process
that is why we are have some inclusive
forum for example trying to have a lot
of dialogue with all the stakeholders in
this area so that they will be part of
our development path in the future
the government is emphasizing
initiatives like workshops teaching
digital skills and modern farming
techniques
SRI surawachi and her neighbors who
migrated to East kalimantan in the 70s
say the project is making life in sepaku
better
let's be grateful that we will be part
of the new capital before the new
capital plan we never got any attention
because our village is far from town and
no one knows it but indigenous Community
leaders he booked in says life was
easier before the new capital location
was announced
they say it's fair for all Indonesians
but which ones we don't want to be
relocated from our ancestors land the
new capital is haunting us and haunting
the future
as authorities scale up Construction in
coming weeks this community is
increasingly losing hope Jessica
Washington altazira in East kalimantan
on the island of Borneo